you know it's interesting because like
you have like um like you said you're
you give back a lot but you also shine a
light on skid row and just kind of the
homeless population in general in l.a
yeah and i feel like during the pandemic
um
i guess homelessness obviously was on a
rise but it also kind of became like the
national narrative about l.a is going to
[ __ ] because the homeless there's people
sleeping everywhere it's like
you know the city can fix this well i
was going to ask you kind of your take
on that because you're you know you're
probably so just like death right death
is a trillion dollar business death
so is
uh fitness
so is homelessness
if there was no homelessness then there
wouldn't be these foundations to help
homelessness which are everyone's got
salaries where everyone's got these over
fluff salaries and
it's like a business you know you got to
feed this and the tax write offs and all
this [ __ ] you know so they kind of need
it to exist
um
and mind you
there are some people that living on
skid row who want to live on skid row
like you know not everyone wants to live
in a house there's a story of this woman
who we got housing for
moved into our house and then set up her
tent in her living room
threw away all the furniture in the
house and set up her tent in the middle
of her living room jesus
shout out to her yeah dedicated it's
dedicated but um
so my goal isn't to necessarily
eradicate skid row for everyone because
i feel like there are people who are
simply who simply want to be liberated
from society who don't want any
fiduciary responsibility
but
the people who do want to get out of it
like i've been doing imagination time on
skid row going up certain people and
getting them to see what they imagine
and 10 out of 10 of them are just
imagining a nice place to sleep they're
like man i just want to live in a living
room with a nice couch into this and
some pajamas they're just they just want
somewhere to sleep and an opportunity
there's thousands and thousands and
thousands of
square foot square footage in factories
downtown that are vacant that i'm going
to buy i'm going to buy i'm going to
turn it into housing i'm also going to
branch it off into my skid row
manufacturing there should be skin road
uh
trash cleanup we're going to start a
community garden there's you know skid
row potato chips because you can grow
potatoes up and i have this whole plan
of you know getting a potato factory and
then making skid row potato chips and
like i'm just i'm just uh
figuring it out did you notice skid row
getting becoming a more like or downtown
just in general becoming a more wild
place the last two years
yeah i know it was always it always was
wild in pockets but it felt like it's
getting crazy man it's feeling like
gotham city right now every time i go
downtown
it's like
it's like i'm like every time i go it's
like damn shit's getting crazy and then
i'll go two months later it's like [ __ ]
i'll go a week later but the crazy thing
is is on skid row it's not crazy man i
feel safer on skid row than on melrose
right melrose here yeah yeah mel rose's
it's hot for sure melrose didn't used to
be like that
yeah of course yeah you know but like
skid row is really a community of
[ __ ] people like it's really like
grandmama's grand uncles cousins it's
like a it's a community yeah there's
some junkies yeah there's some this but
it's really good people man